hi I'm Andre kuznia Rec director of
document and media systems at Wolfram
research I'm giving a talk today on
updating everyone on where we are with
CDF this year I do that every year and
there's always news to tell and details
to learn about so you get my talk
you know every year I give a talk on
where we are with CDF and it's you know
technology that we put out in the world
in 2008 it's been going strong but
certainly changes are coming that affect
the way everything works in the web but
let's talk quickly about how we're doing
with our release cycles actually this
doesn't seem to be saying the right
thing here why have perhaps the wrong
slide there what I meant to be saying of
course is we're now in version 11 and
and what you're seeing here is what I
was saying last year is that we had been
moving our release process into a faster
track by essentially taking everything
that is Mathematica and making it the
player that wasn't the case in the past
because we were dealing with the the
footprint of the player we were trying
to keep it small as possible and so we
were building it from essentially the
opposite direction we were building it
up instead of you know releasing it from
what was being done with Mathematica and
that you know that would throw bugs into
the process things would get missed
things weren't quite always working
right and we realized that you know when
you can put gigabytes on a thumb drive
it really isn't that big of a deal
anymore that the footprint gets bigger
so we're at the point now where we
essentially can release CDF in a matter
of seven days after releasing
Mathematica and that's what we've done
this time around with 1101 and with
version 11 the CDF release was with 10
days so you know we're getting that down
to a week we're probably not going to do
any better than that in terms of the
features that have stabilized
there's not really anything
technologically new in the player itself
that isn't that needs to be spoken of
differently than Mathematica you know
whatever Mathematica can do the see if
player is supposed to be able to do for
the you know depending on what level of
CDF you're producing but just as a
reminder what we were working on last
year and getting sorted this year was
the multi-core support there's a player
pro activation that is in the menus now
for the CDF player copy and paste had
always been kind of finicky and that's
been stable the years-long requests for
repressing the welcome screen when an
application you've developed and put on
the desktop for for your users is opened
from that application then there's no
welcome screen for CDF player whatever
branding you want to put into your
application is what the user sees and
and that kind of skinning is is you know
it's on you at that point and the
connectivity point here is is the one of
the main reasons why the CDF players
built based on mathematical because we
have to make sure that everything is in
the layout that allows for all this
different kind of connectivity and we're
always adding more so you know it's the
I don't quite know what happened to my
slide but I when I was putting that for
a slide together I was making the point
that the Macintosh download size is
around eight hundred megabytes right now
the download size for Windows is a
gigabyte and the download size for Linux
is one-and-a-half gigs and yeah that's
maybe a little scary the installed
footprint gets bigger from that you know
sure you know we've we've all been doing
of this for a long time at least maybe
half of us in this room I certainly have
and you know you could easily balk at
that kind of size of things but you know
when you are getting apps from app
stores and like from Apple or anything
on your iPad or whatever you could be
buying books that are way bigger than
that and it's not like it's
unusual anymore for these kinds of large
data files to go around alright so one
of the bigger points to be made today is
what has been warned about for a while
that plugins are going away we've known
this for a couple years now and all the
major browsers have committed to that so
I've put links in here for any concerns
about what is being said about this but
and this talk will be available of
course so you can look it all up so you
know the the story is essentially a over
for browser plugins and you know flash
is is the one plug-in technology that
everybody committed to for you know the
kinds of things that they throw on their
web pages that include advertising so
it's a sort of thing that's going to be
the last to go under and you know
Firefox will allow for flash to persist
for a while but it's going to be blocked
you've probably already seen blocking
messages when you're using the CDF
plugin and that that's going to persist
with Firefox but at any time next year
the plug-in technology will be gone it's
already gone on chrome and and on safari
by virtue of the fact that this year
they had only been supporting 64-bit
plugins and we don't develop past the
32-bit because we knew this was coming
you know we knew this is going to be
over microsoft edge never supported
plugins to begin with so what does that
mean for CDF on the web it primarily
means that our cloud Interactive's in
the cloud have to have to work you know
they have to do the right thing and
you've probably all experimented a bit
with the cloud and
you know want to have confidence and
what's coming along with manipulates I
have this little basic toy experiment
it's always the same thing I do sine
wave and you know this is a cloud
interaction here so I'm moving the
slider and you're seeing the
interactivity take place with less delay
than you may have seen a while back
we've made significant inroads I mean
we're talking about cutting it down by
you know can we get a millisecond there
can we get 10 milliseconds there you
know what can we do to optimize we're
constantly working on optimization and
if i was showing this to you a year ago
i would have to move the slider let go
have it snap and then booing the thing
would move right now it's keeping up a
little bit you know but you know we have
the benefit of the last mile here on the
internet being closed home you know so
you're seeing it about as good as it can
be right now but this is an internet
interaction that you're experiencing or
that i'm showing you right here so that
that does say something i keep popping
up the wrong window here sorry about
that back to this so you know what are
the next steps from here we're talking
about plugins because we're talking
about embedding CDF content in the web
and what does that mean we you know we
essentially want to make it as easy as
possible we can do that now with the
cloud as well for you to have a very
simple user interaction I'll demonstrate
the issues on that in a moment where you
know you're pushing a button here you're
saying I want this thing to live in my
web page how will I achieve that and
because of putting everything in the
cloud now we're poised to make that
simpler than we've ever had it in
previous years so and and then that it
leads to the question of what does that
mean for your audience when you are
hosting files that require computation
time
from a server and it's not your server
it's our server it's costing us money to
host your CDF files to host your
Interactive's anything where you're
doing computation on our dime is
changing the the the terms really of
what you're putting out in the world and
that's an important conversation we're
having in the company and and we're
working on what that really means for
anybody who's pushing a button to deploy
CDF certainly in the past and it's still
true going forward that if you're
putting a free CD F out on as a desktop
application you know you're giving it to
somebody to play with the CDF player on
their own computer that's great we don't
you know doesn't cost us anything you've
exported it you've put it out there
using their CPU cycles to run this thing
but when you're embedding a CDF in the
cloud in your webpage you're running it
on our servers and and the challenge
there is to do the right balance between
making it an enjoyable and convenient
experience for your your readership your
audience your users and you know
essentially not crushing us with all the
CPU cycles that we have to account for
so the approach to that is going to end
up being where we will allow some amount
of free usage and there will be a
certain threshold at which you the user
of your CDF transitions to to something
where they're told to continue further
they have to download or they have to
log in to their own cloud account to
continue experiencing I'll get back to
questions later so to demonstrate
something like that we I've got a bunch
of links to some demonstrations that
we've been putting together Steven
previewed some of this in his talk so
the idea is your your CDF is is sitting
on the web and the normal experience
would be that somebody can just you
use it right now with the demonstrations
our our plan is to put things up with an
animation that animation is something
you would have your audience see after
they've used up the free cycles that are
available to them so let me just switch
here this button here is enabling cloud
interactivity so this is the cloud
embedded version this is what your
audience would experience on the web
this is a CDF embedded on web page and
it's hosted by our servers there's
there's no file that you had to
transport or put up on your own servers
everything is coming from us but that
includes this preview image so if I've
been you know using this interactive for
maybe you know 20 times and playing
around with it at some point it will do
something like that you know I'll have
used the last interaction that's
available to me as a viewer of the web
page and now I'm being told to continue
further download it that's what this
button would do here or continue in a
web account a cloud account on the
Wolfram site so that that's the way
forward and to get to that from using
mathematica or any of our other products
the objective would be to make this
export process and that's what you're
going to see in version 11.2 Ian can we
say that can I say that 11-2 is where
we're going to make this export wizard
be the thing that gets you the web the
cloud version of everything he's waiting
for me to do the work and then I'll give
it to him yeah okay I promise you that's
what it's going to be because I have to
make it happen yeah we'll do it so
anyway this is the CDF export wizard
this is what you're using when you want
to put a CDF out on the desktop or
in the web as an embedded object i chose
the web embedding method and so you're
currently being asked for what you want
to save out and where you want to save
it in this case I'm going to save it to
the desktop which is already confusing
because it's like wait I thought I was
embedding something on the web so why
are you telling me that I have to save a
file out somewhere so the steps here
involve paths and and you know it's
asking you if you're going to put this
CD F on your website is it going to be
nested in another layer deep or are you
going to put it right next to the the
HTML file that is being embedded in
other words we're exposing too many of
the details of what you normally have to
do to configure a web server instead of
just making it a streamlined experience
like if you're embedding video on
YouTube finally at this last step here
you see what the ultimate goal is and
that is to have a blob of code that you
simply copy and put on any web page that
you want where your content should be
embedded so so this process here got us
you know was it was a compromise and and
so you know here I'm copying this out
and this should have produced output
here that is I didn't give it a name but
but here's the CDF file that I produced
and here's a preview image that was
created for me in order to support the
the web preview of configuration and you
have to get those files onto your server
going forward and I'm saying 11-2 you
will push the button to embed your CDF
content and what you'll get back is that
that code that's it you're done okay at
that point that code goes into your
website and it points to our servers
where the preview image is on our
servers where the manipulate
code is living on our cloud and it's
running from our servers this animation
that's being created here might take a
you know might not be instantaneous it
might take a bit of effort at it's
something you know will create for you
it's being created on our servers so you
know it's a case where that that
animation might not show up instantly
but there will be sort of a placeholder
that says it's coming and then
eventually it shows up it's not much
different then if you put videos up on
YouTube and it takes a while for the
thumbnail images to get processed and
then at some point you can choose one or
you can put up a custom one if you want
we could probably arrange something like
that as well okay so you know that
that's the primary story of where we're
going with how to work with the cloud
I've gone over those details here I
think that it it'll it's finally the
user experience we really kind of wanted
for everyone it does you know there is
the compromise of the efficiency of what
can be displayed in the cloud but like i
said it's always getting better i wanted
to bring up something that is perhaps
comparable to what we call cdf and and
that is just the fact that once we're
talking about the cloud we're talking
about things you can do with our
technologies that put app like
experiences in front of people on the
web that that don't necessarily depend
on the idea of embedding something
necessarily i mean when it comes to
manipulate objects you've already seen
not probably many demos around the
company and when stephen gives talks
where he's creating a cloud object from
the desktop because he's done a cloud
deploy of what he's coding in his
notebook and that thing just appears on
the web it doesn't have anything around
it it's not a web page of your own
content it's just that thing but it's
just a demonstration of putting stuff on
the web in various different for
arms well we've got form pages that we
can create and we've got AP is that you
can create we've got HTML templates
coming together you've seen previews of
the asked technology which is
essentially a way to create a
questionnaire so things are coming
together in a way that you can
essentially you know create interfaces
and applets in in you know in web pages
or you know you you could create this
content in a way that can be embedded in
other web pages such that you're moving
a little bit past just the experience of
of a block of code or a self-contained
applet that you then have to portably
move around you know you're like you're
going right into the the web coding
experience essentially so internally in
the company and probably when we gather
these we we call these microsites and
the idea being that it's you know like
like a tumblr is a micro blog it does
one thing it just what does one little
thing and it's it's very much like an
app experience but it's a web page to do
you go to for that it doesn't do
anything else it did this one thing that
we gave you and and when you're done
with that you move on and go somewhere
else but everything you see displayed
here is configured through the cloud
deployment that is offered through where
we are now with this data our technology
so I think it's worth talking about in
the same context as when we're talking
about CDF okay so let's get back quickly
because I'm just about out of time here
and I want to be able to take some
questions to just kind of wrap up points
so I've mentioned in previous years
portables CDF I won't go through it
again if anybody has questions about
that they can lift me up afterwards
and there's always a talk of what's to
come I'm free for quite a few years now
we've been talking about having a CDF
player on mobile devices on ipad I think
we're waiting for the cubs to win the
World Series for this to come out and I
think that is this year let's hope right
if I haven't jinxed anything so for that
for both sides of it so anyway we do
have something that we are putting in
the beta very shortly and then of course
i always have resource links for where
you can get more information about you
know cdf in its current state all right
i'll stop there and i'll take questions
Dana yep absolutely yeah I mean there's
there's no there's no software download
required when you're making your content
available through the cloud and the the
concept of embedding is really just that
okay you know there's the Wolfram cloud
which is a notebook experience on the
web but you you know you're publishing
something based on a book style or a
bunch of web pages you put together that
you like the way those web pages are
assembled you don't want to have to
convert those all two notebooks for
people than read them as notebooks so
you can just take the juiciest bits
right the parts that are the
Interactive's the dynamic elements that
you really like coming out of our
technology because it's the easiest way
you have to do that and you can cut
those in to your webpage but they're
coming from our cloud servers and when a
user goes to your web page they're not
downloading anything you know and that's
important for the way forward that's
going
I have a wordpress blog for example what
I press export acedia it'll generate a
snippet of HTML I stuck that in that's
it
correct nothing that's it you know I
wanted to be there years ago but you
know we needed all this other
infrastructure to support then shouldn't
I don't think so I mean it is the case
with WordPress that they try to be very
controlling right that's for security
reasons and whatnot of what you can put
into it but when it comes to just an
iframe sort of thing it should be safe
it should be no problem George well you
you do but it's not what it is it's just
it's a zip file and you're giving / your
your audience your customer a zip file
that they unzip and that's it then
they're done you know they unzip that
archive and they browse to the file that
says start here they click that button
and it opens your CDF file which to go
this far you probably are doing an
application that has a lot of additional
resources behind at CDF or it's a CEF
that points to many others you know it's
like a book or it's a pretty substantial
application with a lot of users or
interface features and and maybe the
first CDF that comes up is just the
thing that says welcome you're now using
this this application start here click
this button well the point there is they
can be Windows users and they can be mac
users and it's the same difference
you're giving them the zip file and you
don't have to know what platform there
on the file gets on zip they start the
start here and that's that's a Java file
it just picks which platform you're on
it recognizes whether you're on windows
or on mac and it then opens the mac or
windows ce DF player with thats EDF file
coming right up you know so so it's only
been in the last few years that
Mathematica and CDF player have been
fully copyable from once
system to another you know without
having to have an installer that that
puts in other DLLs or other details you
know so by virtue of doing so you can
have this kind of a setup now it works
well for CDF player because there's no
license involved you know there's no
password there's no machine ID you
couldn't do it with Mathematica because
it would start up and say well you're on
a different machine what's the new
password so that that's why this is
possible but it's big but again it fits
not a thumb drive you know okay if there
are no other questions and I'll wrap up
here thanks
[Applause]